[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the yatan
released fire and blood volume 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rynera targaryen's son aegon the
thirds reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion that attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war the dance of the
dragons was the most devastating war in
the history of the seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons most of
westeros waged war in either support of
queen rhaenyra and became known as the
blacks
or in support of her rival king aegon ii
and became known as the greens
and by the time it was over dozens of
thousands were dead
most of the dragons were killed as well
as most of the targaryens
the biggest supporter of king aegon ii
and the man who fought
the most for the greens as well as
burned the most of westeros in this war
was king aegon's brother
eamonn prince aemon targaryen also known
as aemond one eye or
aemond the kingslayer was a prince of
the targaryen dynasty who rode the most
powerful dragon of its time
mighty vagar vagar was a she dragon of
house targaryen
she was ridden by queen vizagnia
targaryen during aegon's conquest
alongside aegon the conquerors valerian
and their sister rhaenys's marxist
prince stamen and his dragon vogar
played a major role in the targaryen
civil war
by the time of the dance of the dragon
swagar was the hardened
survivor of a hundred battles had grown
almost as large as valerian
and was the oldest and largest of
dragon's investors
her roar was so powerful that it could
shake the very foundations of storm's
end
no living dragon could match her for
size or ferocity
born in 110 ac aemond was the second son
of king viserys the first targaryen
and queen ellison hightower and the
brother of king aegon the second
targaryen
at birth aemond was said to be half the
size his older brother aegon had been
although he was twice as fierce the
birds of aemon that his brother aegon
were the cause of some strife at the
court of viserys the first
the king had named rhaenyra his only
surviving child by his first marriage
his official heir in 105 ac but refused
to change the order of succession after
the birth of two healthy sons
this eventually led to the rise of
queen's party at the royal court
as opposed to the princess's party in
128c when eamonn was 10 years old
his brother-in-law sir lane or valerian
died
eamon accompanied his parents and
siblings to driftmark
to attend lehner's funeral king viserys
had suggested travelling to dragonstone
after the funeral and informed eamond
who out of all the siblings was the only
one yet without a dragon of his own
that he could claim a dragon egg or
hatchling on dragonstone for his own
if he was bold enough annoyed by his
father's comment
eamonn resolved to claim vegar the
oldest and largest living dragon
who had recently become riderless with
the death of laina valerian
vegard was present on driftmark and a
man who knew that his parents would not
allow him near the dragon
went to make his attempt in secret
aemond was caught by his three-year-old
nephew prince joffrey
in an attempt to keep him quiet eamonn
slapped and threatened the younger boy
before shoving him into a pile of dragon
droppings
when joffrey began to yell aymond
climbed on top of regards back
the dragon broke free over chains and
daemon flew two circles before landing
joffrey however had alarmed his two
older siblings
jacaryus and lucerus valerian the four
boys fought with wooden training swords
until aemond called his nephews strongs
as it was rumored they were
bastards of their mothers lovers or
harming strong
having their rumored father's appearance
rather than valyrian appearance of house
targaryen or valerian
jacary is old enough to understand the
insult attacked eamonn again when eamonn
gained the upper hand and began to beat
jakarta savagely losers drew his dagger
and slashed that daemon's face taking
out his right eye
after the incident queen elizan called
for luceries to lose deny his penance
which king viserys refused while
princess rhaenyra demanded that eamonn
was questioned
sharply until he revealed where he heard
her sons being described as trunks
as naming them such was suggesting they
were bastards
and therefore rainer was guilty of high
treason by sleeping with sir harmon
strong
forced by his father aemond eventually
admitted hearing the name from his
brother prince aegon
while he was an unforgiving person amen
would later say that he considered
losing an eye to be a fair trade
in an exchange for obtaining the great
rogar
afterward he often put a smooth sapphire
as a full sigh
in his empty socket despite the loss of
his eye aymond went on to become one of
the most fearsome swordsmen in all of
westeros
as he spent next 10 years being trained
by sir christophe cole
lord commander of the kingsguard on the
first day of 127 ac king viserys held a
feast
to celebrate the return of his health
after the king had left
the feast eamonn toasted his three
valerian cousins
speaking of their appearance mocking
them as three strong boys
eamonn wore knight black armor chased
with gold
in 129 ac when eamonn was 19 years old
his father king viserys the first
targaryen died
eamon's older brother was crowned king
egg on the second targaryen
despite their older sister rhaenyra
having been wizards as chozenair
starting the war of succession known as
the dance of the dragons
at the beginning of the war eamonn flew
the guard to storm's end
to win the loyalty of lord boris
baratheon by betting one of his
daughters
rhaenyra's second son luis results
arrived on his dragon
racks with the same goal of winning over
the baratheons
lost risk however only asked boris to
join rhaenyra for the sake of his past
oaths
and said he could not vet one of his
daughters because he was already
betrothed
so borah spurned his offer when eamonn
threatened lucery stating he
owed him an eye boros refused to love
them to fight under his roof
boris's manners trained eamonn allowing
glossaries to leave the hole
and take off on his drag on the racks
then boris's daughter
marries tauntydamond asking him if
lucerus had removed his balls as well as
his eye
aymond became enraged when he asked
boris's leave
boris told aemond that he had no say
about what
aemond did while not underneath boris's
roof
and allowed him to depart aymond mounted
vegar and pursued his cousin
avenging the loss of his eye by killing
losers and the wrecks
mushroom claims eamonn located the boy's
corpse
and removed both of his eyes to present
them to lady marys on a bed of seaweed
aemon was known the raptor as a
kingslayer among his enemies
his own mother alison hightower and
grandfather odo hightower were horrified
by eamon's actions they'd still hope the
war might be ended diplomatically
but by killing one of her sons aemond
had ensured rhaenyra would fight to the
bitter end
otto haytower famously told him you only
lost one eye how could you be so blind
and then vegard's next major fight was
in the battle of rook's nest
varagon the second's army set a trap for
reigning targaryen
riding the dragon mileys when she
arrived she was ambushed two-on-one by
aegon the second riding sunfire
and aemond on regard even so miles was a
large dragon
and did not go down without a fight at
the end of their fall to the ground
vegar was relatively unharmed
but sunfire was crippled and nearly
killed aegon ii himself was burned over
half of his body
leaving him semi-conscious for the next
full year
as he slowly recovered in his stead at
alison's behest eamon stepped up to
become prince regent
and protector of the realm as prince
regent aemond gathered an army together
with sir kristen cole
the hand of the king now in command
eamon demonstrated that as a swordsman
and a dragon rider he was a deadly
opponent
but also hothead with no sense of
strategy
he decided that the real threat was not
rhaenyra on dragonstone to the east
but the main armies of her supporters
massing under his uncle
daemon and harrenhal therefore he let
out
all of fagon the second's remaining
armies in the crownlands nor to attack
herohole
leaving the capital city with only a
skeleton defense
daemon however had planned on this and
simply abandoned harrenhal
his army moving to the west where he
destroyed the lannister's armies
meanwhile daemon himself flew his dragon
to king's landing
very near a small fleet in the east
augmented by dragons was able to capture
the lightly defended city there was no
siege as the city watch were loyal to
daemon
and supported daemon as soon as he
appeared he made his niece and wife
rhaenyra the queen of the seven kingdoms
eamonn arrived at harehole to find an
empty castle
and quickly heard the news of the loss
of king's landing as well as destruction
of their forces in the west
eamond was driven into such rage at his
failure that he nearly killed the
messenger who brought the news
in petty revenge he then used vegard to
burn every wooden structure in harehole
the second time the castle was blasted
by a dragonflame
eamon then impetuously abandoned his
main army to launch a one man one dragon
boar against rhaenyra's followers
in the riverlands burning out entire
towns and personally destroying vast
swaths of territory
with him he took his bedmate the seer
alice rivers
while devastating even this proved to be
folly the army he had taken north to
harrenhal was left to retreat south
through the riverlands
with no dragon to defend it rhaenyra's
forces in the region managed to loop
around from defeating the lannisters and
surround cole's army
outnumbered three to one aegon the
second remaining army was wiped out in a
decisive battle
and cole himself killed daemon hunted
long for aemond and vegard
but eamonn would flee ahead of him and
other searchers
he knew that vegard could kill any
dragon in a one-on-one fight
and his hit and run attacks would draw
out two or three of rhaenyra's other
dragons
from other fronts in the war as they
hunted him in vain
eventually despairing of the war daemon
waited alone with his dragon characters
in the ruins of heronhole
as a challenge to aemond knowing that
aemond would only face him in a
one-on-one fight
he thought he could win because his
dragon was the oldest and biggest of the
remaining dragons
being almost the size of valerian but he
was wrong
as demons dragon was just as fierce and
battle proven
amen could never dare to duel daemon one
on one with a sword on foot
as damon was the best warrior in his
time period and eamonn
knew it but aemond had another advantage
vegar but not even that was enough to
beat daemon
after 13 days eamonn arrived along with
a pregnant alice
she stayed on the ground as eamond and
daemon took to the air for the final
mighty duel between vegar and characters
in eamon's final exchange with his uncle
damon he said to him you have lived too
long uncle
and damon replied on that much we agree
it was an
aerial duel that took place in the skies
above harehole and the god's eye
between two of the most powerful living
dragons swagar and charaxes
and the writers prince aymond and prince
daemon targaryen
the duel was said to be a sight to sea
the sun was setting as the two dragons
took to the sky
so bright was the dragon fire that small
folk feared the sky was aflame
when characters attacked vagar she
ripped upon his stomach
and tore one of his wings but then
characters fast and his jaws around her
throat in a death grip
these injuries forced them both to cease
flying as they tumbled to the water
below
daemon dueled amend to death at the
climax of the fight as he never fastened
his saddle daemon stood up on characters
and leaped at aymond whereupon he drove
his dark sister through eamon's eye
and through his neck just a second
before hitting the water
eamon's body that was still chained to
the saddle went underwater
along with vegar was only recovered
years after the war
the dark sister still impaled through
his call
the battle above the god's eye ended in
the deaths of both riders and both the
dragons
eamon was 20 years old when he died
daemon was 49 when he died
unlike heyman's body however demons was
never found
singers say that daemon lived to spend
the rest of his days in secret with
nettles
but most historians disagree what
happened to aemon's child with alice as
well as with ellis herself
remains yet to be seen aemond is
definitely going to be one of the most
important characters in the upcoming
prequel show
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace